in the opening scene we see several
undercover CIA agents getting
assassinated in Moscow by the Russian
governments under the leadership of KGB
director yesiliav nailed that their
heads are brutally decapitated and sent
to the U.S embassy as a chilling message
the scene then cuts to five years later
and we see a man named Sammy who is on
the lookout for potential models for a
paris-based agency his journey leads him
to a local Moscow Market where he
notices a beautiful young woman named
Anna selling Matryoshka dolls Sammy
extends an offer to Anna proposing that
she consider a career in modeling with
all living expenses covered by the
organization the latter thinks for a
while and eventually accepts the very
next day Anna arrives in Paris and is
introduced to the modeling agency there
she meets an operator named Dorothy and
the agency's head John Dorothy then
shows her the apartment which she'll be
sharing with other models Anna is
surprisingly assigned with the photo
shooting session the following day
without any practice or training as a
result of this she initially struggles
with posing and facial expressions must
be tough but being a fast learner she
quickly adapts to her new profession
delivering impressive poses and
expressions after a tiring day Anna
returns to a room only to find some
fellow models engaging in Intimate
activities in her bed she confronts them
but the group makes fun of her and asks
her to join in as well come Anna we all
share our butts frustrated Anna Leaves
and decides to share a room with another
model mod one evening the agency holds a
dinner party for all its stakeholders
including the models during this John
introduces Anna to Oleg philinkov one of
the partners of the firm Oleg seems to
be captivated by Anna's Beauty and
openly flirts with her after a brief
conversation he asks her out for dinner
and she agrees two months pass by and we
see the pair kissing at a luxurious
hotel suite when Oleg seeks further
intimacy Anna hesitates deeming it to be
too soon two months she asks more about
him as well as about his profession in
response he reveals that he supplies
weapons to war-torn countries for a
living after retrieving that information
she needs Anna goes to the bathroom and
takes out a hidden mic from her outfit
she then takes a moment to calm herself
and then retrieves a handgun to shoot
him dead back to three years earlier we
see Anna who lives with her abusive
boyfriend named pyotar it turns out that
she has been enduring years of her
boyfriend's domestic abuse she is forced
to participate in stealing money from
the credit cards of kidnapped foreigners
and if she refuses she gets beaten up as
a result of these tortures she is ready
to do anything to escape the life she is
trapped in in pursuit of Freedom Anna
submits multiple applications to join
the Russian Navy through various forms
yet receives no response one night
pyotar and his accomplices abduct an
American citizen subjecting him to a
violent assault while demanding the ATM
card's pin as usual Anna is powerless to
intervene and can only remain inside the
car this time they are spotted by the
police prompting them to drive away the
Chase Begins and pyotar roughly drives
through the streets of Moscow in a
desperate bid to outrun the cops before
long their car collides with another
vehicle causing it to crash and flip
upside down thankfully pyoto and Anna
managed to survive with minor injuries
the pair then hastily makes their way
home on foot upon their return Anna
notices a KGB agent named Alex waiting
behind the door he attaches a silencer
to his handgun and shoots pyotar to
death despite the Grim's sight Anna
remains calm and unaffected which leaves
an impression on the officer Alex seems
to know everything about Anna and offers
her a fresh start to work for the KGB he
outlines a plan involving one year of
training and four years of field work
promising her eventual Freedom believing
that it might be another trap Anna
refuses the offer and cuts herself as
the blood drips down Alex encourages her
to put Faith in herself rather than rely
on others this finally convinces Anna so
she covers her wound and accepts his
proposition after a year of training
Alex presents Anna to the senior KGB
Handler Olga the latter is reluctant to
hire Anna under her Department if she
thinks Anna is just a pretty face who
can be used as a Honey Trap however Anna
swiftly impresses Olga with her Keen
intellect and exceptional skills in
chess as a result Olga assigns Anna with
a mission to eliminate a Russian drug
lord at a cafe within a strict time
limit of five minutes Anna is completely
unaware of the presence of armed
bodyguards and the situation inside the
cafe nevertheless she enters the cafe
and draws her weapon on the drug lord
only to discover that it's unloaded as a
consequence the armed bodyguards begin
to attack her this forces her to engage
in close combat surprisingly Anna turns
out to be a skilled fighter and she
takes down the guards one after another
as she wipes out all of them the drug
lord smacks her head from behind he
attempts to strangle her but she somehow
manages to reach a fork and repeatedly
stabs him until he succumbs to his
injuries but despite all of this Anna
exceeds the time limit by one minute
leading Olga to deem her mission of
failure later Anna confronts Olga in her
office accusing her of setting up a trap
to get her killed in response Olga
suggests that one should always be extra
careful because danger never sends
warnings she then drives Anna to her new
apartment and before departing hands her
a stack of files regarding her next
Target instructing her to study them in
detail the following day Anna is going
through the target's files when she
receives a call from Alex he appears to
have feelings for her so he asks her out
for dinner Anna responds that she would
love to see him but she is already too
busy at the moment as a result the two
agree to meet some other time the
mission day finally arrives and it turns
out that she has to execute Oleg and it
does it efficiently as shown in the
previous scene here it is revealed that
the entire Paris model scouting
operation was part of the kgb's plan to
assassinate Oleg Anna intentionally
positioned herself at the local market
where she caught the attention of Sammy
a part of the plan she flew to Paris
where she established a new career as a
top model in order to avoid suspicion
Olga endorsed her to establish a
relationship with Maude after killing
Oleg Anna used a body double to wipe the
hotel's security tapes now that's some
spy style at presents Anna is being
interrogated by a CIA agent named Lenny
Miller regarding oleg's murder in
response she asserts that she did indeed
go to the hotel as shown by Street
camera footage Anna explains that she
waited for Oleg in the lounge but he
didn't show up lacking concrete evidence
against her the agents let her go in the
next scene Anna returns to Moscow after
successfully completing her Mission
while in her apartment she is visited by
Alex they appear to be seeing each other
after a long time so they immediately
start making out trading tongues for the
motherland the following day Olga Alex
and Anna go to meet vasilev
unfortunately he refuses to honor the
original agreement and dismisses the
notion of granting Anna freedom in five
years when she presses the issue he
culture at gunpoint asserting that
former agents pose a liability to the
agency and that the only path to Freedom
is death even Olga and Alex are unable
to utter a word in front of vasilev
disheartened and returns to Paris and
continues her career as a model on a
particular day she calls Alex expressing
her discontent at being unable to live
freely Alex tells her not to lose hope
as there might be some way out Anna asks
if he will support her if she ever plans
to run away to which he replies that
he'll try his best soft answer a few
days later Anna is summoned by Olga for
the next mission the target is a man
named wurtenberg who is waiting for an
escort to satisfy him in a hotel room
Olga informs her that the room contains
no cameras or listening devices because
of this she won't be able to monitor her
and she is on her own in this mission
after a while Anna disguises herself as
an escort and enters the target's room
she asks wurtenberg to wait for a minute
pretending to use the bathroom inside
she retrieves a gun a catches a silencer
and walks out to shoot him dead
following this she retrieves
werthenburg's suitcase and returns to
Olga in the other room of the same Hotel
Olga doesn't appear to be satisfied by
her work because she took 12 minutes
which is longer than she usually takes
moreover Anna didn't bring the index
finger of the target as mentioned in the
job detail due to this Anna returns back
to the target's room mutilates an index
finger and brings it back at this point
of time Anna breaks down in tears and
asks how many more she has to kill
sensing her frustration Olga advises her
to take a week-long vacation with mod
and his vacation proves to be really
useful as she needed it for a long time
she then returns back to work in a
completely refreshed State I am ready to
kill again from that day onwards Anna
carries out numerous tasks efficiently
which impresses Olga simultaneously she
also excels in her modeling career
several months pass and vasilyev who is
pleased with her performance summons her
to Moscow for a meeting as soon as Anna
lands in Moscow she proceeds to the KGB
headquarters and meets Alex overwhelmed
by their emotions they quickly sneak
into a storage room and get it on after
satisfying themselves Anna enters
vasilia's cabin where they have a
conversation over a chess game while
seated nearby Alex notices Anna's
suspicious hand movements under the
table in an unexpected turn of events
and a
vasilyev in the game and at the same
time she grabs her gun and shoots him
right in his fat head The Scene then
flashes back to six months earlier when
Anna was tasked with eliminating
wurtenberg on that day as she walked out
from the bathroom she was startled to
find agent Lenny and his team waiting to
apprehend her red-handed once cuffing
her hands Lenny offered her to work for
them as a double agent in exchange for
one year of her service he promised her
freedom and to secure life in Hawaii
left with limited choice and accepted
the offer before parting ways though she
asked him about how Lenny managed to
catch her to which he replied that he
recognized the way she held her bag
Lenny's got away with bags this entire
scenario is the reason why it took 12
minutes to return to Olga that day
during her one week vacation Lenny came
to check up on her and they had a brief
conversation inside a closet he asked
her for dinner but she couldn't do so
because Olga was still spying on her
however they secretly met in his room
that night and the two made out Lenny's
up to more bag tricks since then they
start started to meet more often even
after returning to Paris one day Lenny
assigned her with a job to execute
vasilia because he was threatening the
respectful relationship between KGB and
the CIA he also shared with Anna about
how he was the head of CIA in Moscow
when vasilyev killed nine U.S undercover
agents in a single day in order to
persuade Anna he offered early Freedom
upon successful completion of the
mission and she well she agreed back to
the present day after assassinating
vasilia Anna immediately holds Alex at
gunpoint and injects him with a sedative
making him shape following this she
extracts critical data from vasilia's
computer onto a flash drive and leaves
Alex despite his drowsy State manages to
crawl toward vasilia's table and
activates an emergency button beneath it
alerting the security team however Anna
being a highly skilled fighter
incapacitates all the guards on her way
out despite this she fails to reach the
Rendezvous point in time where Lenny is
waiting for her this unfortunate delay
leads Lenny to believe that Anna has
betrayed him prompting his lead after
this he heads to Mod's place and
instructs her to notify him as soon as
Anna contacts her Lenny then flies back
to New York where he's awarded for
successfully eliminating vasilia one day
while in his office Lenny receives a
message from Anna summoning him to meet
at a specific coffee shop in a park
Lenny heads to the location only to
discover Alex instead both men recognize
each other and inform their respective
teams who are secretly backing them up
shortly after Anna arrives on the scene
and shares kisses with both men now
that's a double agent it turns out that
she deliberately arranged the meeting
with the two Rivals she returns their
crucial information she had previously
stolen to each of them however she
claims to have kept a copy which she
will expose if either party betrays her
by accepting the return of their data
Lenny and Alex allow Anna to walk away
towards her Freedom unbeknownst to all
of them the meeting area is under the
surveillance of Olga shortly after Anna
Leaves the meeting Olga catches up to
her and fatally shoots her for betraying
the KGB Lenny and Alex find themselves
holding each other at gunpoint but are
ultimately forced to retreat three
months earlier Anna and Olga met for an
information update during this meeting
Olga admitted that she was aware that
the CIA got Anna because she had noticed
cuff marks on her hands during the
vertenberg mission and she knew that
wurttemberg preferred whips and Feathers
despite this Olga told her to do what
they say allowing her to kill vasilia
Olga had a personal motive for this
decision she wanted to take vasilia's
position and Slater revealed that Olga's
shooting of Anna at the park was staged
as Anna had been wearing a bulletproof
vest they immediately use a body double
to fake her death while the real Anna
slipped into the sewers changed her
clothes and removed the wig from her
shaved head before Vanishing into the
crowds finally free in the aftermath of
these events Olga is appointed as
vasilia of successor just as she wanted
as she accesses her computer she
discovers Anna's database attached with
a video message in the video Anna
expresses her gratitude to Olga but also
reveals that she has recorded their last
conversation station in which Olga had
admitted to supporting the cia's plan to
assassinate Vasily if she did it in case
Olga betrays their agreement Olga smirks
and then fulfills in his final request
which is deleting her identity from the
KGB database subscribe for more videos
like this turn on notifications and
leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching